how's it going bros i haven't slept i
feel like [ __ ] but there's one thing
that makes me feel even worse pickup
artist the truest form of torture i
can't send this i can't do it this is my
cringe threshold i can't watch it we
have this guy
walking past the girl
pulling up with the howdy howdy girl how
do you do
oh
well she's at a library yeah yeah she's
studying what you studying
a test
which one
i can't hear you
[Laughter]
because you're at a library but dude but
was that i can't [ __ ] why you're
whispering oh man
do i know you
my name's glenn nice to meet you
[Music]
nice
not a regular handshake but a gentle
touch that's how it's done i'd i'd hook
up with flying absolutely
you said um oh it's math no m cats em
okay okay i mean yeah i thought it was
like had something to do cat related
but i've never heard of them cats you're
probably not smarter than me so that's
probably why
it's just like harder than sats but kind
of like g-master like outside really
standardized
i heard cats i don't know what's up with
that
okay
so you're still in high
school okay okay oh you're still in high
school you're a child
what was that question i see yeah
and you're going for
chemistry
my major is um
societies
okay
interesting
what does that entail like i'm guessing
some sort of um
anthropology
oh my god is he gonna score or what dude
i mean i don't how to i don't know how
to talk to anyone okay but i think
trying to force these conversations
cannot be better right
so like what is this and well why am i
just hey
you seem epic can i get a number i can't
do it either okay very cool very cool
what's your test
january 23rd look he keeps asking about
her [ __ ]
that's it
amazing oh god why do they upload it
[Applause]
oh nice yeah film her and not creepy at
all
[Applause]
what are you doing
um we're gonna meet with our friends
they're friends can i be your friend
no um your new friend no no
[Music]
oh god the pain the pain his teachers
are very good they show exactly what not
to do at first i'm like i can handle
this howdy
but i did go to colombia
really yes several years ago
several years ago
several oh
god make it stop very much stop him yes
and i like you
do you have a boyfriend no i don't
i would like to get to know you
um i've just had a drink of wine
and i can't remember if you told me your
name
could you tell me your name
johanna right
steve i'm dying i'm actually dying
this is death i've no death now
nothing to fear
i i hate this so much so you're going to
a a party now yes
yes
you're my friend
so you're with all your friends and
i guess it would be a bit weird if i
came along to that party
[Applause]
yeah it would be weird i'm glad you
realized now leave
leave this poor woman leave her strange
wouldn't it be a bit strange
if i came along
wouldn't that be super duper weird
what are you doing
stop it you're not all goddammit
i don't know what can we do
i don't know maybe what should we do
because i'm attached to you now you're
never going out of here
nice eyes
i can see a nice genuine you know
maybe oh look at that oh he's ready look
at that that's the face of writing girls
you see that face run
run
it's there okay let me do it
god
women i apologize for every man
[Applause]
you're just smelling out she saw the
camera right
she was licked in the camera
[Applause]
and the skirt
look she's staring right into it what is
happening you our colombian men are they
very forward as well
yes
so they come and talk to you and they
like this and they're like touching you
like this
is that what they do
oh god
send him to jail as long as you like the
guy right it depends i mean if i was
like this like hello
i like you you would be you wouldn't
like it would you
what
what what does that mean it being short
talking to her boob what is that you're
like
thank you yes
you're like tallman don't you
that's about the only thing i got going
for me
yes i'm
i'm very tall guess my height
that's right
eight feet [ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
no
[Music]
i'm very persistent aren't i
i have to go holy [ __ ] i'm very
persistent on that i
i get what i want
and i'm very tall aren't i
would it be so weird if i forced you to
go to like what what that's the worst
i've ever seen jesus christ
so this is a clip from a pickup artist
that wasn't supposed to be uploaded
because you know we get to see the best
clip right the epic wins whoever
uploaded that clip right there yeah i
bet he thought it was so cool how he
forced himself into that poor porn lady
uh but here's one that wasn't supposed
to go up i just want to say hi
hi
[Applause]
i'm sorry i mostly i just actually
wanted to meet you you have a very
feisty adorable look about you
oh i appreciate it but
you guys all know each other
nice it's like he comes to he approves
these two girls they're not interested
they're doing something else he's just
interrupting them but
she's trying to send him signals like
well thank you but you know we're trying
to and how do you guys
you try to cut me up i caught you up
cutting me up you guys look absolutely
adorable today
you're welcome i didn't make you
adorable though i just noticed it i
should thank you
for adding to the i don't know
we're in the middle of a conversation
actually oh
abba
that's a whole city full of women i can
leave that's what you think to yourself
don't say that out loud i was just i'm
just saying
so polite
so kind
i'm sorry i just like i i'm i'm not used
to people not being nice to me i don't
know how to deal with it i just wanted
to meet him
i'm not used to
people not being nice to me
that's so crazy
oh jeez
this is pain it's like he just walked up
to these people they're not interested
but he's still
trying to force them
to talk to him
it's so weird cool oh there's three
girls that's not two are you like
students you work are you nice people do
you i mean i don't even know work
work yeah
i'm sorry i think we got off on the
wrong foot i think we're having a
conversation and we'd like to yes
you don't mind
and i want to see that we haven't seen
you haven't seen each other yeah go
leave really it's funny i've been i've
been alive for 31 years i haven't not
yet to meet any of you it's been so long
and i haven't seen any of you and i just
missed you
my entire life
it's been really tough i've had a really
i believe that but there's a lot of like
second placers in new york i think
what does that mean what was that yeah
that was like their 500th attempt to try
and make you leave what the [ __ ]
maybe
i don't think that's gonna happen
unfortunately
just sad
i'm really depressed now
see i just i actually just got up the
courage to like talk to girls i was
talking my therapist for a long time oh
my god what are you doing
what
i'm talking to my therapist so i get up
the courage to talk to girls anymore
i can't believe you did that to me
what were you guys talking about what's
like literally what's the conversation
oh my god dude [ __ ]
i can't believe it i can't believe this
i don't mean to be an ass but seriously
i just want to meet you guys is that so
bad no yeah but you've been there ten
minute minutes dude stop it stop it is
it so bad to be a hopeless romantic and
meet three girls and just want to meet
them
you hate me right now but you would
really i would really appreciate if you
could just let us
return to our conversation
just tell me i'm ugly like tell me i'm
ugly and awful and you want me to leave
just tell me that
running short on time we haven't seen
each other in a long time
she's leaving town tomorrow we really
just would wouldn't mind like
that's fine how is this going on
so it goes to the point where they
actually have to leave because he will
not leave them alone
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh that's so funny
guys biggest problem
with girls is fear of rejection right
but these pickup artists have just
created this shield for fear of
rejection that they just don't give a
[ __ ] no matter how uncomfortable he just
doesn't care that it's so strange
and i'm so sorry so the context behind
this clip as far as i understand is that
there's some sort of pickup artist
conference they've asked women to come
there and just act natural
and then pickup artists will sort of try
and
communicate with them or pick them up i
guess to see what will happen as a
showcase and it's just the weirdest
worst thing ever a little bit wacky
would you rather do you have ocd or
would you rather have like 80d it seems
like you may have possibly both of them
no i don't have either one well which
one would you choose
i wouldn't how do i approach a woman hi
howdy
do you have od
do you have add or ocd
which one would you choose
i think for a while people were trying
to turn uh pick up artistry into some
psycho analytic game
and it just took weird curves
they sort of do yeah i'm asking you a
question why wouldn't you choose one i
just don't want to
why are you i mean are you scared of
having one is that like it's
no i said why would you pick one huh
why won't you play along with my weird
twisted game huh you scared
hi
what's the problem with you what's the
goal here hey
you want to go home have sex huh what
would you
how does this go over there you're there
all right
it's a hypothetical situation i mean is
it really that hard for you to imagine
which one would you would rather have
is he just trying to piss her off like
to me like add like you seem to have add
because your eyes are tripping okay i'll
pick 80d
or ocd because
it seems like you're obsessed with small
little details i mean which
one
ocd yeah which one is it the whole the
question was to pick one and now you're
good now you're fluctuating as though
you don't really have a formulated
opinion so i don't really i'll pick 80d
am i that i think you're a creep
this is going great
watch and learn pick up artists
hell yeah what is your name jennifer
you're not going to shake my hand are
you scared like do you think i'm
am i dead i think you're a creep
yeah well okay you said that was such a
smile though is that is that that's
funny i mean it's funny when creeps come
up and touch really
but it happens
but you're not running away you're
sitting there well i'm being paid to say
you're gonna be forced to
at least spelling it out well you're not
running away are you well yeah because
i'm paid to be here as part of this
conference this weird creepy thing you
guys set up but you're not running away
are you
that's what all women say to me is
they're being paid to sit next to me
right so is that i mean i could do
better than that in terms of
aggression too i mean that's not i can't
i'm not really i'm a kickboxer but
so you're gonna you're gonna kickbox me
no but i'm just saying i'm not really
that
i don't really worry about things like
no i mean
you just have a picture of her what is
happening what do you like to eat where
are you from
that was smooth
are you guys learning anything
[Laughter]
that's so good
you guys get anything out of this [ __ ]
oh god i'm dying oh
bro
just for the record what do you like to
eat where are you
what do you like to eat where are you
from how old are you
where are you sibling hey
every question at the same time are you
guys learning anything
is that pure sarcasm are you gonna
answer one of the questions or not
i don't know okay do i have to no i
don't have to
you don't have to uh
and now you're twitching your hair like
like
you're thinking because you're a psycho
me
what do you think you think i'm like a
sexual uh pervert or how would you in
what way would i be a psycho um
i think you're more like a mind figure
me yeah
i can't imagine how you would come to
that formulation
okay so now at the end they break down
what had just happened okay
watch and learn was she completely
comfortable yes or no
no
is that okay yes or no
no was i comfortable no
no the answer is no that is not okay oh
my god
were you uncomfortable no is that okay
yeah
oh god there's more hi
yes
oh this guy's a legend
this is changing the game
no words necessary
what is this this is what i was talking
about
what kind of gum is that
um orange no i'll trade go no thank you
please
kylie smell yours no
what the [ __ ] is this they paid women
to sit down and be forced to have these
conversations
is that like a little heart oh there's a
little heart i heart
no no
um no i heart doggies
do you
oh that's sweet
yeah
what's your name sarah nice to meet you
sir
oh nice
nice real smooth
i can't do that
this is the worst
that is weird
how come you know where jewelry what's
the story behind that i do my jewelry
but like are you are you phobic or
somehow
hey the classic psychoanalyze yeah do
you have any mental disorders huh
that mean anything about that anyone see
these all right that's the bottom that's
all i can stomach
just be yourself please the love of god
holy [ __ ] just don't be cringe it ain't
that hard i've never been creature my
life
[Music]
anyway thanks for watching subscribe for
more videos and i see you bro tomorrow
you thought it was game
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes are emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this